Mark Ruffalo Jamie Lee Curtis and other
celebs react to the post-election
protests that's what we need right now
the 57 year old actress took to Twitter
on Wednesday to share a jarring video
from an anti-trump demonstration in
Chicago writing it begins protests and
more protests my niece in Chicago is
already voicing what we all are feeling
hashtag not my president ladies and
gentlemen the next president of the
United States after president elect
Donald Trump's victory on Tuesday night
several protests have broken out across
the country
Mark Ruffalo shared a video to Instagram
of his experience at the love Trump's
hate fest outside of Trump Towers in New
York City meanwhile John Legend and wife
Chrissy Teigen chose to protest the
outcome of the election from home with
their six-month-old baby girl Luna John
posted this adorable pic of his family
all cuddled up together
and wrote in the caption quote in this
time of conflict and uncertainty it's
clear that we all need more love
embracing my family has made today full
of love and light despite the bad news
love is universal we all need it we all
can give it and it will ultimately win
over hate this is so important to me
you